In Hungary, the European Parliament votes to sanction Hungary...
...for allegedly undermining the European Union's democratic values and rule of law.
Hungary says it will seek legal ways to challenge the decision.
In Venezuela, Brazilian and Venezuelan defense ministers meet...
...to discuss issues such as military cooperation, human and narcotics trafficking,...
...border violence and the exodus of millions of people from Venezuela.
In Iraq, a jihadist used a car bomb to attack a restaurant north of the capital,...
...killing five people and injuring 32.
The restaurant is known to host travelers returning from Baghdad to Dahuk,...
...according to local police.
In the US, President Donald Trump assured citizens...
...that first responders are well-equipped for Hurricane Florence,...
...a category 4 storm expected to hit states on the southeast coast.
Finally from Britain, a British court is deciding whether Indian magnate Vijay Mallya...
...should be extradited to his homeland...
...to face charges of money laundering and conspiracy.
Mallya denies any wrongdoing.